ونتابع ايضا مع يوسف عزت المستشار لقوات
الدعم السريع معنا من الخرطوم سيد يوسف ما
رايك بان الهدف العسكري لقوات الدعم
السريع قد انتهى او بالاحرى قد فشل
وبالتالي هي الان يعني
اقصى طموح هذه القوات هو الحفاظ على بعض
المواقع في العاصمه كي لا تفقد التاثير
السياسي
يا اخي السؤال الذي يطرح نفسه هو الذي
يفترضه المتحدث السابق بين القوات القوات
الدعم السريع هدف عمل العمليه العسكريه
وهو هدف يوجد في راسها او لا لانه الدعم
السريع
ولم يحدد هدف ولم يبدا المعرفه ولم يحدد
هدف محدد استخدم الدعم السريع
الاستراتيجيه الدفاعيه خلال هذه المرحله
تحركات الجيش استطاع السيطره على مواقع
استراتيجيه للجنس ليس سريع هدف معلن حتى
يتم التحدث عن الفشل دعم السريع تفضل
عمليه انجلابيه كانت يهودها النظام السابق
حدد اهدافها واستخدم الجيش فيها واستطاعت
دعم السريعي يتشالها الهدف الوحيد للدعم
السريع الان الذي يريد تحقيقه هو ان يكون
القرار
ان لا يعود نظام السابق باي شكل من
الاشكال باستخدام الجيش او باستغلال
الدعايه او باستغلال اي من من الوسائل
التي تمكنه من العوده والان حتى هؤلاء
انقطع في العوده الى الحكم واصبحوا يديرون
معارك في الفضائيات يديرون معارك يتمنون
ان الجيش يهزم الدعم السريع نحن العدو
العدو الذي حددناه ليس القوات المسلحه
السودانيه العدو الذي هاجمنا والذي اتخذ
غرار الحرب هو عدو معلوم للشعب السوداني
عدو قدمه الشعب السوداني في ثوره ديسمبر
عدو ما يتمكن في مؤسسات الدوله هذا هو
العدو الذي وهزمناه هذا العدو الان يتراجع
الان القوات المسلحه العشرات من الضباط
برتب كبيره يعلنون انضمامهم لقوات الدعم
السريع ويسلمون اسلحتهم الالاف من الجنود
يخلعون كعكههم ويغادرون ارض المالكه كل
الاستنجاد بالقوات القادمه من الولايات لم
تستطع دخول الخرطوم معظمهم سلموا اسلحتهم
هذه المعرفه خاسره انا اقول للبرهان الذي
تعامل مع الفنون للانقراض بالحكومه قل له
او بفايد العبث او غفاد العبث لانك تقتل
ابناء الشعب السوداني لانك تدخن البلاد في
ازمه لانك في القاهره تضرب المدنيين
وتقتلهم هذه خلال هذه الهجمات الطيرانيه
الطائرات
الميدانيه سيدي يوسف هذه المعطيات التي
تقدمها تقابلها معطيات مناقضه تماما
يقدمها الجيش وبالتالي
الحقيقه الواحده الثابته الواضحه على
الارض واستمرار هذه
المعارك
وخفه او تخفيف حده هذه المعارك عندما يكون
هناك هدى معلنه بواسطه دوليه الى اي مدى
على المستوى العسكري على الاقل يستفيد
الطرفان من هذه الهدن لالتقاط الانفاس
يا اخي نحن نحن نسيطر على مواضع واسعه جدا
في العاصمه الغربيه حين اتحدث عن ذلك انا
اعلم ان الالاف من المواطنيه او الملايين
من مواطنين الولايات الخرطوم يجلسون امام
الشاشات ويمكنهم الخروج الى الشارع غير
قوات الدعم السريع نحن نلتزم نحن نلتزمه
اعلنا ان الهدنه
انسانيه منزل امس نحن قوات
لانقطاع المياه تنقل المياه من مواقع
بعيده للمواطنين
وتعطيهم المياه نحن حولنا قواتنا في
الهدنه الى قوات
لمساعده المواطنين
الطيران المعلنه ويراها الشعبي كله
والسودان الان تما السودان مفتوحه خلال
العالم يراغب فان كان سياره واحد متحركه
العالم يرى العالم ليس ليس عميانا نحن
نريد الهدنه لصالح الشعب السوداني وقد
تعينه واعلنا التزامنا بالهدنه لكن
تهاجمنا قوات ونحن نشك ان القوات التي
تهاجمنا جديره القاده المعروفون للجيش
السوداني هذه العمليات يا سيدي
الهجوم على المواقع ومحاوله استرداد مواقع
يستولى عليها دعم الدعم السريع فنحن هنالك
قرار اخر داخل الجيش هنالك من هجير
المالكه لان البرهاني يخرج يقول انا ملتزم
بالهود لو كان باجي اقول ملتزمين بلغي
القيادات المعروفه لكن من يدير من يخرج من
يعطي الطيران اوامر للضرب من
هذا ما نتحاير يحيرنا انه هل هنالك قياده
واحده للقوات المسلحه ام هنالك مراكز
متعدده
يعني انت تكرر ما جاء في
مواقف وبيانات لقوات الدعم السريع عن ان
هناك تعدد
قوه او التعدد اراء في مركز القياده او
تعدد قيادات ربما داخل الجيش
هذا هل ما تقولونه بهذا الشان مبني على
معلومات او فقط على تحليل كما تقول الان
وتقول اننا محتارون ما الذي يحصل هل لديكم
معلومات ومن هي مراكز القوه التي تضغط على
البرهان في في الجيش كما تكررون في اكثر
من مناسبه
يا اخي هنالك خلايا وتنظيم هنالك تنظيم
اسلامي لديه مكاتب معروفه لدينا داخل
الجيش هذا التنظيم هو الذي اتخذ قرار
الحرب هذا التنظيم يجبر البرهان والبرهان
متعامر معهم هو الذي يدير الحرف هو الذي
اعلنه هو الذي يحرك القوات من خلال الضباط
الاسلاميين الذين يديرون المعركه هذا هذه
حقيقه علمها الشعب السوداني وهي سبب الحرب
لاننا طالبنا بتنقيه صفوف الجيش وصفوف
القوات المسلحه في عمليه الاصلاح من عناصر
النظام البيئي هذه هذا كل سبب
هو اتخذ الحرب
سريع مرتبط بالورقه وورقه
سريع في ورشه الاصلاح الامني وطالب بتنقيه
صفوف الجيش وكل مواطن نظاميه من عناصر
النظام المضاد
للاصلاح العسكري ونحن وقعنا مع البرهان
على ورقه من ثلاثه مراحل تبدا بالاصلاح
الامني اصلاح القوات الامنيه الدمج
والتحديث هذه ورقه موقعه عليه بشهود القوه
المدنيه
هذا هو سبب الحربي تخزن
قرارا بسحب جميع القوات
المسلحه في ورشه الاصلاح الامني واتخذ
قرار الحرب بتدمير الدعم السريع بالسلطه
والمرهان تواطى معهم هذه هي الحقائق الان
يخرج البرهان يقول انا مستعد للتفاوض مع
مع قاده الدعم السريع يخرج الكباش يقول لا
نحن لن نجلس مع غاده الدعم السريع هل هذه
مؤسسه عسكريه لديها انضباط اعيدها العام
يقول انه يجلس ويخرج الدعابه اخر يقول انه
لا يجلس ويصرح عقاده التنظيم الاسلامي لدى
البرهان بالغريب في صفحتهم قالوا اذا
البرهان ذكر الاتفاق الايطالي العمليه
السياسيه مره اخرى سنضعه في الاعتقال هذا
هذه هي الفوضى التي تحدث في البلد نحن
نواجه حرب مع قوه لديها الرغبه في العوده
الى الحكم فوهه البندقيه
سيد يوسف تقول تقول يمكن عندما كنت تتحدث
عن خريطه سيطره قوات الدعم تقول يمكن
للمواطنين ان يخرجوا
يعني ينظر الى قوات الدعم
واين اين تسيطر ضيفنا قبل قليل فعلا كان
يقول ان قوات الدعم تتغلغل في صفوف
المواطنين وهناك استياء
ورفض من المواطنين
للدخول قوات الدعم الى هذه الاحياء الامنه
اضافه الى ذلك هناك اتهامات ايضا لقوات
الدعم بانها ليس فقط تتغلغل داخل الاحياء
السكنيه وتعرض هؤلاء
السكان للخطر بل انها تدخل الى
المستشفيات هذا ما حصل في مستشفى الخرطوم
اكبر مستشفى دخلت قوات الدعم طردت الطاقم
الطبي
وادخلت اسلحه وادخلت قوات وذخيره الى هذا
المستشفى ماذا تفعل قوات الدعم
بهذه المستشفيات وبهذا التصرف
يا اخي ارجو انك لا تبني
تحليلك او او معلوماتك على معلومات مضلله
اول شيء قوات الدعم السريع لا تدخل
الاحياء تتواجد في الشوارع الرئيسيه
العامه لديها حوادث ارتكازات
للمواطنين لا تدخل بيوت لا تدخل حياه
تهتمي باحياء والمناطق التي تسيطر عليها
تقوم بتامينها نحن نشرنا ان هنالك لصوص
هنالك
لانه معظم بيوت الخرطوم بتحديد بحري ام
درمان معظم البي
وت خرج الناس من الخرطوم نحن نؤمن هذه
البيوت هنالك من يتعرضون لهذه نحن منها
بالنسبه للمستشفيات هذه اخر اكاذيبهم لا
توجد اي قوات دعم سريع داخل مستشفى
الخرطوم ويمكنك ان ترسل مراسلتك الى
مستشفى الخرطوم لترى اذا كانت دعم السريع
ادخلت الاهلي
لمستشفى الخرطوم هذا كلام
لا يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار نحن هنالك طيران
طياره سمعنا ان هنالك طياره تركيه ضربت في
وادي سيدنا قالوا دربها الدعم السريع وهم
ينفون سيطره الدعم السريعه على هذه
المواقع لا هذه اكاذيب اعلاميه هذه هذه
محاوله لتشويه صوره الدعم السريع الدعم
السريع يعلم تعلم تعلم نقابه الاطباء
ويعلم الاطباء اننا نحن منسحها لنا عبور
الاطباء عبر الجسور التي نسيطر عليها
لغناهم بسياراتنا الى المستشفيات الى
مستشفى الساحه الى كل المستشفيات نحن
الذين قمنا بنغلط
كيف نعتدي على مستشفى او ننقص سلاح
المستشفى لماذا وما الهدف وما علاقه
المستشفيات بالمعارك اصلا هذه احاديث لا
صحه لا هذه دعايه حرب محاوله تشويه صوره
الدعم السريع كل شيء نسبه الينا نعم
اولياء الدبلوماسيه
نهب عربات المواطنين كل شيء قيل وهذه
فرديه وهذا كذب يجب ان لا يصدقه شعبنا يرى
ويعرف يعني شكرا لك يوسف عزت المستشاره
السياسي لقائد قوات دعم السريع حدثتنا من
الخرطوم